mine you didn't even know when you
joined you didn't know they had never
seen The Big Bang Theory I thought it
was a game show
that's Mayim Bialik confessing she'd
never seen her hit show before landing
the part of Amy Farrah Fowler oh it's a
tiara the 43 year old actress appeared
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show on Thursday
with her entire Big Bang Theory cast
mates when she revealed the news someone
had told me that in some season of The
Big Bang Theory they mentioned that the
girl from blossom is a scientist so when
someone told me that I thought oh my god
must be a game show like a trivia thing
I had no idea that it was a very popular
sitcom apparently right so I mean
somebody must have said it's not a game
show before you signed on well my
manager says they're looking for a
female Sheldon Cooper and I said who's
Sheldon Cooper et caught up with maíam
later that day while on the red carpet
at the casting Society of America's 34th
annual R Dios Awards where she opened up
about the series ending you know Jim
Parsons said something when we were on
Ellen that it's something that kind of
keeps evolving and it kind of keeps
catching you off-guard you know Kaylee's
very emotional onset and I think there
definitely will be emotion but I'm more
of a private person with that so I think
that when I go home that night after the
last taping it's gonna be yeah stiff
glass of bourbon I feel like it's kind
of like with life you don't really get a
heads up about what's happening in 99
episodes so I think we're kind of open
to anything you know we have a lot of
like we have a lot of morbid jokes were
making like maybe we'll all die in a
fiery crash with the terrible things but
no I think we'll all be okay and I don't
know I was saying maybe all the females
will be pregnant at once I don't know
though I have no idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]